as you know the grammys the other night
featured what was essentially soft
pornography now that's really what it
was if you go back to like 1990 and you
look at what soft core pornography was
at the time
that is what now appears on mainstream
television shows in the united states
today and the shift in american life
from what was private activity to public
activity that must be approved by the
public is pretty astonishing
and it's worth tracing for a second
because what we have seen
is that there was an argument that went
something like this in the 1970s what i
do in my bedroom is my business
and that argument is somewhat convincing
for those of us who just want to live a
life where we are left alone by others
the idea that consensual activity
between adults in private
is basically none of the government's
business and societally speaking
can be condemned by others but really is
is not generally
the the the thing that people should be
discussing in public
that that at least is kind of fair right
there's at least something to that
argument but the argument from what i do
in my bedroom is my business
two what i do in my bedroom is your
business should be celebrated
should be put on a pedestal and if you
refuse to celebrate this and put this on
a pedestal this means that you're a bad
person
in some way it is a complete reversal of
public morality because there there's a
a process that is used very often by the
political left
and it goes something like this if
you're polite you'll leave me alone
right you won't say that my activity in
private is sinful
and people go okay that's that like okay
i guess
and then it goes well i want to say what
i want to say publicly and if you say
anything then you're really being
impolite
you say well but don't i get to have an
opinion and they say well no if you
if you don't celebrate what i am doing
then you are being impolite
politeness becomes a weapon at a certain
point being
being polite to people who wish to tear
down all traditional values
is a large-scale mistake and what we
have seen in the united states is the
triumph
of what some philosophers have called
expressive individualism the idea
that you get to do what you want and the
rest of the world is supposed to adapt
to you this has been written into our
supreme court decisions
famously in planned parenthood versus
casey justice anthony kennedy one of the
worst justices of the modern era wrote
an entire swath
of the decision in which he suggested
that the constitution provides us all
our own right to define life liberty and
the nature of the universe
somehow this also allowed us all to
define the nature of human life itself
such that you could kill a baby in the
womb but this idea
that you have a right to define the
universe around you is ridiculous it's
ridiculous on its face the universe
around you exists it is an objective
reality
you don't have the right to redefine
society that is not in accordance with
reality
and yet that is exactly what we have
been pushing now somebody is going to
win the cultural battle somebody's going
to win the cultural space and the people
who have won the cultural space in the
cultural battle
are the people who have exploited the
politeness of traditional conservatives
in order to completely tear away
any semblance of traditional values and
that's how you end up with what you saw
on the grammys right there's some
deeper roots to this sort of stuff and
yes we've seen this sort of nonsense
in public for decades at this point but
i think it is fair to say
that there is even a step from britney
spears and madonna
faux making out on the mtv video music
awards in like 2003
to people full on simulating lesbian sex
on stage
in the middle of the grammy awards so if
you didn't see it
cardi b and this is not for youngs this
is not for the children although
the grammys wouldn't warn you about it
obviously actually this is very good for
kids according to folks on the left this
is just sex positivity
it's excellent as long as your kids are
old enough to know what sex is
then they should also understand that
gender is fluid all forms of sexual
behavior are decent and good and
non-sinful and and ought to be
celebrated
and dr seuss is really bad if i ran the
zoo is super damaging to your 10 year
old
if you're if your 8 10 6 year old reads
if i ran the zoo they will inevitably
come away
a brutal vicious racist but if they
watch
whap being performed by a pair of women
who
in any other polite company their
behavior would would be
stripper behavior i mean this is
stripper behavior on stage with music i
mean that's what it is
then that apparently is good for your
kids or at least it's okay for your kids
at least it's not bad for your kids if
around the zoo is bad for your kids this
sort of stuff is not bad for your kids
according to the mainstream left at this
point right this should be celebrated
it's good
okay anyway here's what that looked like
[Music]
the heights of western civilization
happening right here
okay i mean it's just unreal
obviously the glories of western
civilization from beethoven to this
in just a couple of hundred years really
strong stuff and by the way commentators
suggesting
that this sort of stuff is on par with
shakespeare sir i'm not kidding you
there are commentators have said this
this is on par with shakespeare it's
like modern shakespeare
one commentator compared it to king lear
which makes sense if you were dropped on
your head repeatedly as a baby and then
smashed by a truck
that makes perfect sense okay so the
reason this is relevant is not because
this particular video is in and of
itself all that important it's just
indicative of a cultural rock that has
set in
so i'm not the only person who believes
this i think tens of millions of
americans believe this
that if you watch this and you don't see
cultural rot at work it's because you
don't wish to see
the cultural rot at work that there is a
large scale difference
between the the music
of duke ellington and this garbage right
there is a very very large scale
cultural difference
between the sort of behavior that was
celebrated in america's past
and the sort of behavior that is
celebrated today in america and the
behavior that's celebrated today is the
most fringe behavior
it is the most it is the most
exhibitionist behavior because that
exhibitionist behavior is breaking
boundaries you see
and that's the real key this is not
culture this is not even counter culture
this is anti-culture
right it's just garbage designed to tear
things down and that's why it's being
celebrated right the reason that this is
a quote unquote important song
is because it's tearing down cultural
barriers to female pleasure as though
female pleasure resides apparently in
the simulation of lesbian sex on stage
of the grammys which is a
very odd take to say the least okay so
candace owens
made this point the other day on fox
news she said that
western civilization is not going to go
on much longer if this is the sort of
culture we produce
she happens not to be wrong about this
this prompted a spat with cardi b
for some reason cardi b just cannot help
responding to candice owens
and this prompted a rather fascinating
twitter exchange mainly in how the media
covered the twitter exchange
so candace there's a brand new show here
on dailywear there's a reason you should
go subscribe to dailywire right now and
use promo code canvas to get 25
off and yeah i'm not above a shameless
pitch for candice's show because this is
the kind of stuff that candace
does right i mean candace is going to
step into culture wars and she is going
to
emerge victorious so cardi b tweeted out
the clip of candace talking
about her dumb crappy song
and she wrote yay we made fox news guys
because she is such and just like
shakespeare would
just like shakespeare would guys she can
aristotelian figure
cardi b what an important cultural
figure
candace owens replied just at me next
time directly you are a cancer cell to
culture
young black girls are having their minds
poisoned by what you are trying to
package and sell to them as empowerment
i'm one of the few that has the courage
to tell you the truth you should thank
me
okay that is correct i'm sorry that
cardi b's behavior is not in fact female
empowerment
female empowerment is a woman not
turning
herself into a sex object for the
viewing of men because let's be frank
about this that's exactly what cardi b
is doing in that song
a huge number of men are consuming that
product in the same way they consumed
playboy
in the 1960s to pretend otherwise is to
be ridiculous
okay so this conversation continued
she said the reason my comments always
get you into your feelings
is because deep down you know what i'm
saying is true you're in a position to
empower young women to aspire to
something more than taking off their
clothes
but you don't feel that you can be more
again
not wrong okay candace continues along
these lines if you think making your
husband a sandwich is a sin but popping
your vagina into another woman's vagina
in front of the world is power
you're a lost soul and that was a
response to cardi b suggesting it was
really really bad that candace owens had
once said they should make her husband a
sandwich
she said you always love to mention my
husband's skin tone so let me ask what
color are the people that are
encouraging you to strip in front of the
world
this is a good question who owns your
record labels who owns cbs and the
grammys who made the most money off of
your whop
you sold it to who says ken is just
destroying cardi b in real time millions
of young girls follow you at your best
you're self-deprecating and humorous at
your worst you're naked shoving your
vagina into another woman's vagina while
thrusting a topper you're at your worst
on the grammy stage do better cardi b
okay correct okay so cardi b responds
and then she responds with a fake tweet
from candace
which just shows you what a genius cardi
b is she's a lyrical genius
she's a behavioral genius she's
incredible at what she does so she found
a photoshopped
tweet from candace okay the photoshop
tweet and this is something that the
left for some odd reason loves doing
they love doing this they will
photoshop a tweet from me saying
something i've never said and then
they'll run full stories about this they
actually did this at the av club at the
onion
and then never retracted it because this
is what they do so there's a fake tweak
from candace
that was going around saying yes my
brother did cheat on me
my husband did cheat on me with my
brother yes he said no when i asked you
to join them okay it's a fake tweet
it's an obviously fake tweet and cardi b
then tweeted out not you talking about
two women thrusting their vaginas
together while your husband and brother
slap bleeps and balls together well
would you look at that
wow so cardi b such a genius she bought
into an obviously photoshop tweet
okay full-on obviously photoshop tweet
so candace replied i'm literally
laughing out loud cardi
my dear that is clearly a photoshop
tweet only one of us has a husband that
sleeps around which is
fact check brutal but true man
don't get into twitter fights with
candace i think is the theme of this
this particular
episode wow yes it is
it is there's a certain irony to the
fact that the cardi b fans
are constantly going around analyzing
other people's sex lives while uh
cardi b's husband is uh engaging in in
other activities
cardi b then tweeted back this wasn't
photoshopped you was trending the whole
day when you tweeted this and it was
published on a lot of blog outlets
you're right mine sleeps around your
sleeps set yours sleeps at your home
with your brother
bleep boxing while you tweet me um
yeah so semi literate response there
from cardi b
and then candace replied what the actual
hell are you talking about are you dead
serious right now trying to substantiate
a photoshopped tweet
asking one more time before i get the
lawyers to make you publicly admit
you're lying and embarrass yourself
okay and then she says for your
information i do have a brother a
private citizen who you are slandering
right now with this photoshopped image
that you're now publicly claiming you
saw tweeted in real life
you want to admit you lied now or get
sued so i can expose you as a liar
i win either way and then cardi b
tries to reply quote not you being mad
at me for what you tweeted and is
published on a public
blogs i ain't made it up honey google it
yourself
and then she proceeds to tweet out a
bunch of bizarre fringe
blog websites as substantiation for the
idea that candice tweeted something she
clearly did not tweet
so finally candace concludes yes
just spoke with my family i'm 100 suing
cardy for that nonsense you can't just
start throwing out wild lies against
private members of my family because
you're upset someone called you out on
your degenerate performance
i'll keep you all posted okay now here
is the thing if you look at the
headlines
in the media today cardi b gets
completely destroyed in this particular
exchange
i mean just wrecked in this particular
exchange because
number one she has no response to the
idea that she is
not actually acting in an empowering way
she's actually acting in a degrading way
toward women
if you if you wonder if that's true ask
yourself if a man made that music video
of two women acting like that okay and
the two women were not famous
would that be considered an act of
empowerment or an act of degradation
i'm old enough to remember when robin
thinks white line what was it called his
uh
his white i think was called white line
right that's the name of the song i'm
old enough to remember
when that uh blurred lines blurred lines
that when blurred lines came out
this was considered a deeply
exploitative act
because not not only because of the
lyrics but because of the way that women
were treated by the camera
okay so if you take away what you know
about the people who are participating
in these particular
videos the videos themselves are
objectively degrading
but cardi b has no response to that so
instead she proceeds
to tweet out a bunch of
lies about candace's brother who is a
private citizen
cardi b cardi is informed that their
lies and she continues to double down on
that
now here is the headline let me read the
headlines from our mainstream media from
our establishment mainstream media
rolling stone cardi b fires back at
candace owns his criticism of wap grammy
performance
cardi b has chickaly fired back at
candace owens criticisms of her steamy
what performance with megan v
stallion at the 2021 grammys on sunday
now that is some
seriously excellent media coverage right
there right the story is not
cardi b has no defense for her own
behavior proceeds to
level defamatory accusations against
candace's immediate family
right that's not the headline the
headline is cardi b is just clapping
back guys
she's clapping back yahoo
yahoo news cardi b and candace zones
threatened to sue each other after claim
pundit's husband cheated
with her brother
cardi b and candace owen's twitter spat
ends with legal threats
said page six it's just it's amazing
here's the bottom line cardi b is a
heroine to people who wish to destroy
our culture and wish to destroy
traditional institutions and wish to
destroy traditional values and so she
can get away with anything
that's pretty much the story of this
particular exchange
and there is something to this on a
broader level which is that if you are a
person who wishes to destroy our culture
if you're a person who wishes to destroy
traditional institutions and values
then you are of use to an entire wing of
the political side of the aisle
we are in a cultural battle right now to
preserve
basic ideas like a man is a man and a
woman is a woman
and men and women don't have exactly the
same roles in all aspects of societies
and that traditional marriage is a good
thing and that decency and sexual
behavior is a good thing
and that modesty is a good thing you
know things that societies have learned
over the course of thousands of years
are being completely ripped away and
anybody who is
of use in ripping away those values is
now considered the heroine
or hero in any particular exchange and
it doesn't matter what they say or how
badly they get wrecked it doesn't matter
what they do
it doesn't matter if they say defamatory
things it doesn't matter if what they
are doing is deeply exploitative
of themselves and others none of that
matters the only thing that really
matters
is what the quest to do is about and
what this is really about
is in the end making sin public and
religion private
making a lack of values the common
currency and the common standard
and making values something you're not
supposed to say out loud and if you say
values out loud this makes you a bad
person
if you say values out loud this makes
you intolerant and cruel
and people can be as intolerant and
cruel to you as they want to be if you
say anything about traditional values
because
you are being judgmental you see they're
not being judgmental about you
and going after you and wrecking your
life and suggesting that you ought not
have a job if you disagree with them
politically or on values
they are not the aggressors in this
culture war even if they are the
aggressors in this culture war
so yes these things matter and you can
already see the headlines after today's
podcast
shapiro spends 20 minutes talking about
these issues right
the reason i spent 20 minutes talking
about these particular issues
is because they actually matter hundreds
of millions of people consume this
garbage
hundreds of millions of people it is
garbage with message the media know this
if the media didn't think it were
important
they would not be pushing it if the
media thought that this was a completely
unimportant thing
the media would not be treating it as
though or an important thing and this is
the trick the media love to play
what your left-wing media love to do is
treat
a fringe a fringe element of society
as the key to unlocking all freedom in
human society and then when you say well
no that doesn't make any sense and
that's not good for society they say how
dare you even notice we're doing this
this is the common theme in the in the
culture wars
the the left will take a hill the right
will say well
do we want to die on that hill and the
left will say
well you shouldn't die on that hill
because the hill doesn't matter why are
you even noticing we took this hill
and every time the right surrenders the
hill the left takes another hill
there is no limit there is no end to the
hills that the left will take here
okay because every hill is a victory for
the left in their war
against traditional culture in their war
against people who believe
in again basic things like
marriage and and purity
and innocence and decency and modesty
like all of these things which societies
used to treasure
are things that have been considered the
reverse of good they are now sinful and
bad in and of themselves
that that is where we are at this point
in american society and it is worth
noting
it is worth noting who is on the side of
people who are
publicly performing semi-pornographic
acts
on stage to the cheers of the media and
who are the people who oppose that and
who are considered the villains and who
are considered the heroes in these
particular situations
because that's a good way of telling who
you don't want near your kids or
educating your kids it's a good way of
telling who you don't want
with their hand at the tiller of our
culture
if you're the type of person who cheers
on the whap performance
but you think that anybody who sounds
off against this sort of stuff publicly
is the problem i don't want you anywhere
near my kids and i don't think anybody
should want you anywhere near their kids
you shouldn't be educating children
your value system is perverse you have a
problem
because let's be frank about this it is
not for you about adults getting to do
what adults want to do in the consensual
privacy of their own bedroom it is about
cramming down on society a standard of
what everybody should do and the kind of
behaviors that everybody should engage
in and what happiness actually means
which according to too much of our
society
is simply boiled down to whatever
self-identity people choose
mainly rooted in in sexual behavior
life is a lot more than that as it turns
out and happiness requires a lot more
than that as our hedonistic society is
beginning to find out in truly amazing
measure
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button